welcome back everyone
It's Charlie
This will be my full Invincible
Season 2 Episode 1 Video. Congratulations,
You made it
It's been a couple of years since season one,
but we finally got season two episodes,
so if you're brand new to the channel,
be sure to subscribe to get them all.
I'll be doing weekly episode videos.
they're going to be airing the first four weekly.
Then they'll take a break in air, the second
for like the second half of the season, early
next year some time.
But they didn't say exactly when the second half
is going to premiere.
careful for spoilers.
If you haven't seen the episode yet,
we'll just start at the beginning, work
our way through, shot by shot.
Talking about Easter Eggs WTF moments,
starting with the episode titled A Lesson
for your Next Life is meant to be a reference
to a couple of things metaphorically Invincibles
next life after Omni-Man
his father left the revelation of his true heritage.
What the village termites are planning for Earth
that's all.
Still a really big thing that he has to deal with.
He just hasn't got to that point yet.
Like he's still dealing with the actual grief
in the aftermath.
pretty soon we'll be talking
about what the rest of the village termites
are planning for Earth in the aftermath, too.
Like on the other side of the equation,
you still have Omni-Man who's out there.
He'll come back into the story eventually.
In the village,
termites will come back into the story still a very,
very big threat But basically Mark
is kind of starting his second life.
He's kind of like rebuilding his life, so to speak.
the episode title, is also more
of a literal reference to the multiverse.
Angstrom Levy's storyline in the alternate version
of Invincible that we see at the beginning
of the episode, who sides with his father
it winds up taking over that version of Earth.
in fact during the episode,
the main version of Angstrom levy
even reveals that in most alternate universes
that Invincible winds up siding with his father
and they wind up taking over the planet.
He turns evil, basically.
so? It's actually very unusual
that this main version of Invincible turned
good, turned against his father.
that's one of the reasons why he didn't
want him to die at the end of the episode.
Like, No, no, no, we actually need him for later.
He'll be really important.
but this first
half of the season is basically all Angstrom
Levy's stuff, like he's the main villain
for at least the first four episodes.
I don't know if he's going to be the main villain
the second half of the season,
but we'll see about that.
the first half of the season.
We're kind of dipping our toes
in the Invincible multiverse.
It'll become a bigger thing later in the story too.
But because it has been a couple of years
since they released season one.
They do an extra long recap
before the actual episode starts.
the real opening scene starts
on that alternate earth showing you what happens
when Invincible turns evil sides with his father
and they take over the planet.
they're in the middle of a fight with the immortal
and I don't think the original comic
book said too much about
what went down in this universe.
They caused him to side with his father.
But angstrom Libby did say that that happened
in most dimensions. so.
In most cases, he wound up turning evil.
I think part of the idea is what was different
in the main universe that caused them to be good
with all of his positive relationships,
like the positive influence of his mother
or the positive relationships
he had with his friends.
And he doesn't have those.
Or like his mother
wasn't around in the alternate universes,
so much easier for his father omni-man
to influence him to join the Guild.
Termites.
They basically want to show you, though,
this alternate version of Invincible,
even though he is
evil, is very, very similar to the main version.
Who is Good?
This version of Omni-Man is also pretty much exactly
the same as the main universe version.
Their fight is also meant to kind of foreshadow
the journey that the main Invincible
is going through this season.
Like during the fight,
Immortals says he's just like his father,
and it's meant to be an insult in this case.
But later in the episode
when the main universe, Mark
is talking to Cecil,
he insists that he's nothing like his father.
He's not going to turn out like him.
Cecil's right to be cautious, though,
because they use this first part of the episode
to show you what things look like
when he decides to side with the build from.
It's like he goes very, very badly
because he is nigh Invincible.
Like not totally Invincible yet,
but he's getting stronger and stronger by the day
Like during the fight, they want to show you
that he's not quite as strong or quite as good
or experienced as a fighter as the immortal.
But when his father Omni-Man shows up,
he makes quick work of him.
see you to remember.
That in most universes,
Invincible will theoretically
become more powerful than all the termites.
Given enough time.
Like he's just like a bodybuilder.
They can make themselves stronger over time,
and because they virtually stop
aging at a certain point,
they can theoretically live forever
and just continue getting stronger and stronger
and stronger throughout the years.
so the really isn't like a limit
to their power level.
but with most versions of Invincible here
like you're seeing them
at the beginning of their time,
like their powers are just activated so
they're at the weakest state
that they'll probably ever be.
we'll kind of see this through his development
like the next couple of seasons, like he'll continue
to get stronger and stronger and stronger.
he'll have to be if he's in a fight,
the other will try to eventually show up.
probably going to be a while before that happens,
though, like people wondering when conquest one in
this are going to show up.
There's like a lot of stuff
that happens in the comics
between season one and what they're doing right now
before they show up.
their actual fight scene here is pretty solid.
It's cool to see how things go down
When he and his father fight together.
They're basically unstoppable,
effectively Invincible.
Just to make more puns on the title,
Technically, Omni-Man is powerful enough
to take over the planet himself.
We wanted, but that's really not the filter my way.
Like, his whole mission is to create a half breed
son set up that son is the ruler of the planet
and then move to another planet
and just repeat the process over and over
and over again ad nauseum,
because they'll just theoretically never die.
they're basically taking over the universe
the slow way.
there's a very important reason why they're using
that tactic that we'll get into later this season.
Like they tease that in the trailers will price
see some Easter Eggs for that in a couple episodes.
their couple really dark jokes about Immortals
powers When Merc squishes his head and
I think the idea is
that theoretically he could heal himself
if they were able to stitch them together.
But he's squishes them so hard that he's effectively
as close to dead as you could possibly get.
They reveal
what's happened to the rest of the planet
because this is meant to take place after
they've already conquered the planet in the Immortal
was really just distracting them away
from the Resistance's base.
they play back a recorded message
that Invincible did about
the village mites taking over the planet
and what it was actually going to look like.
they're basically going to wind out treating Earth
like a glorified colony,
taking its resources in treating the humans
kind of like cattle
like as long as they don't cause trouble,
they will be left alone for the most part.
one of the notable changes
in this alternate universe
is that he does say the full line I am Invincible.
Usually they just cut before he says Invincible to
the title, which they do at the end of the episode.
Like that's the big trope
of all the Invincible episodes.
then they reveal this
universe's version of Angstrom Libby,
who does not have multiverse powers.
He sneaks to their base.
We meet their version of the Guardians of the Globe,
who are mostly the same.
They just look a little bit different.
But all the relationships seem pretty similar.
the green water is meant to be organic material
that Atom e created.
It just helps them
sustain themselves underneath ground.
one of the other changes in this universe too,
is this version of robot is a little more open
about his true self.
Like he walks around in clear view
with his body visible to everyone else.
kind of like this version.
The character doesn't hate his own body
as much as the main universe version
did they reveal Invincible
and Omni-Man killed their version of Rex.
Explode the null energy that Engstrom Levy plans
to use is just a form of energy that's super strong,
effective enough to do something against the build
from ice, but it barely scratches Omni-Man
that's them basically
saying that they're nigh Invincible on this planet.
They also clarify that this universe is universe
number six, four six, which I think is
meant to be a Robert Kirkman Real life
Easter egg for the Marvel 616 comic book universe
because there is a marvel crossover
with Invincible Comics that he actually wrote.
That's right.
Way back in the day,
there was a Spider-Man crossover with Invincible.
Invincible appeared inside a marvel title.
So like Engstrom, Levy is meant to be able
to portal to the Marvel Universe
is like one of the other alternate universes
he has access to.
But even though that's Canon in the comics,
I don't expect to see
any big Marvel cameos
or Spider-Man cameos for that matter.
During Invincible Season two,
the showrunner was kind of coy about that.
People asking like, Will
there be a big Spider-Man crossover?
Like the comics
I'm not going to hold my breath for Marvel or Sony
letting them borrow the Spider-Man character.
but the Marvel Universe is technically canon
to the Invincible multiverse, in
I know the follow up question that a lot of you
are asking now what would happen in a fight between
Omni-Man in Homelander because both Invincible
and the boys are Amazon series.
So it'd be much easier to cross those series over.
They actually joked about that too,
in most of them agree.
Like Robert Kirkman, all the Invincible people
agreed with the boys creators and all those people
that omni-man would wreck Homelander
just the way the character is designed.
He's meant to be way,
way more powerful than Homelander.
really big coincidence
that they're both characters in Mortal Kombat one.
So you could actually both play them
against each other and actually do that fight.
they wind up finding their base, either
killing or crippling everyone, basically
finishing their takeover of this planet.
Omni-Man kills this version of Robert
in like the coldest possible way.
when he tells Omni-Man you too will eventually die,
he is correct.
Like eventually Omni-Man will die,
but not for a long, long time.
end, they want to show you how twisted
this version of Invisible has got, like how evil
he winds up being He snaps Adam Eve's neck
so they can keep her kind of like a pet.
The same way that the main universe
version of Omni-Man talked about his wife
basically the same sentiment,
like he thinks of earthlings as pets now.
And that's how he's going to treat Adam Eve.
basically
keeping her against her will, unable to move
because she'll be paralyzed
for the rest of her life.
that's why he so much worse,
because killing her would have been a mercy like
No, no, no, I would never kill you.
I'm just going to keep you for all time.
but you can kind of blame
the bleeding of all the different minds
and these other angstrom Libby's into his own mind
because he says in most universe is the alternate
Invincibles always wind up turning evil.
So all of the other angstrom
Levy's probably hated their versions of Invincible,
That's kind of why he winds up
being a tragic villain,
because initially he had very altruistic purposes
for wanting to do this and wanted to get Invincibles
help, at least the main version of the character,
because he had turned good,
unlike the other alternate versions.
whereas now he's kind of twisted into this
super villain kind of state
trying to get revenge against him
instead of trying to heal the multiverse,
when in fact he himself was responsible
for causing the accident.
So like, he should be blaming himself,
not blaming Invincible.
then we finally go back to the main universe
version of Invincible
and see him staring at the mountaintop
where Omni-Man almost wound up killing him.
He's got this PTSD from the events in season one.
There's this montage showing him going around
trying to clean up messes, take down villains,
basically atone for everything that happened
and prove to the world and himself that he's
a hero and everyone can trust him again, the song
they're playing is Radiohead's Karma Police.
The lyrics are meant to be a reference to everything
Mark is going through right now.
Like the whole concept of karma just in general.
They're a bunch of characters
they featured in Season one that they bring back
as part of all of his takedowns.
this is elephant.
He basically has the same powers as an elephant.
He's meant to be a parody of the Rhino
in the Spider-Man Marvel Comics.
these thugs, he takes down work for Titan.
That's his symbol on their chest.
Remember, Titan took over Machine Head's Syndicate
after they defeated him.
So he's like the new crime boss in town.
The lava villain is called Mag Maniac.
He's a parody of molten man from the Spider-Man
Marvel Comics.
And this is Tether Tyrant.
He's a parody of Doctor Octopus,
both Spider-Man villains basically,
he has a couple of PTSD flashbacks
to the fight with his father.
He remembers the train.
That was probably one of the most WTF things
during that episode.
they actually turn that train scene into Omni-Man
fatality during the new Mortal Kombat game.
They just released a trailer for a little while ago.
it goes so hard.
these soldiers
that show up with the stars on their arms
and the special armor
from the Global Defense Agency.
Basically Cecil's souls, normal human army,
just wearing high tech gear.
And I love the way the regular cop here
reacts to it, Like, okay, fine, whatever.
Just do your thing.
I'll just sit over here and wait Yet imagine a world
full of superheroes and supervillains
is like this for a lot of normal people,
like normal law enforcement agencies.
We're just sit here and wait for the superheroes
to take care of this.
it's also a little bit like this in the Boys
universe, too.
But the difference is, in the Boys universe,
all the superheroes
are kind of dirtbags
and don't really care about the police officers.
they go back to their house, they watch the news,
they sort of address the aftermath of omni-man
and what's going on with his mother,
how they're kind of dealing with it.
one of the big changes that they made to season
two in future seasons
is basically expanding the season
because the episodes are an hour long.
So they have like way more material to fill.
So Robert Kirkman and the writers
basically gave extra story to a lot of the side
characters like Mark's mother that they didn't
really give her in the comics,
basically giving everybody their own little arc.
like all the Guardians of the Globe stuff,
they get a bunch of extra material
that wasn't in the comics.
Then we go back to the Global
Defense Agencies prison.
We see the Mueller's again after season
one who are taunting the guard that they crippled
the last time they escaped the main angstrom
Levy teleports them to another world
to get their help, finishing his device,
basically starting their relationship.
when they're escaping,
they pan around to the other cells.
This is multiple whose duplicates brother
who's on the Guardians of the Globe.
Basically, they have the exact same powers.
they got them because their ancestors were cursed.
the only difference
between them, between brother and sister
is that the brother multiple works for the order.
They're like an evil organization
in the world of Invincible.
then we meet.
The main version of Angstrom
Levy, played by Sterling K Brown.
I mean, he plays
all the different versions he'll be the main villain
for at least this arc of the show.
Basically, he's able to teleport to any universe
in the multiverse,
he can't teleport around within the same universe.
He can only teleport to other universes.
he's also got a son who has the exact same powers.
We might wind up seeing him in a future season
at some point.
Maybe the autism this season.
the way that he explains it, though,
the other angstrom Lev, he's out there
like any of the other thousand that he gets.
None of them have powers like he has.
when he says that he'll leave the Mueller twins here
in this wasteland earth forever if they don't
agree to help him, that's also foreshadowing
for something that he does in the future.
when Mark goes back to school,
Todd going full 180 on him, trying to be all
nice is also meant to be the same arc
that Mark is going through himself right
now, basically trying to prove to everyone that he's
not going to turn out to be like his father.
no, I mean, well, I'm actually trying to help
everybody now.
he's still going out with Amber here
at the beginning of the season.
They always start out with them
wanting to go to college together because
they both wind up getting into the same college,
like having a normal life.
But the whole idea is that you can't really be
a superhero, like the demands of being a superhero
are too much for doing all the normal human stuff.
So at some point, like all these different threats
that he's dealing with on Earth, all the village
termites, stuff that will eventually catch up
with him in all the extra drama with his father
like it'll all come rushing in in probably
won't it, destroying his personal relationships.
So we'll see how long his relationship with amber
winds up lasting.
They kind of blew past
this super quickly in the comics.
But like I said, the show is expanding
on a bunch of these side stories.
Then he basically asked Cecil for more work,
like he asked them to call on him for more help,
but he doesn't really agree to it
until Mark says they'll join
the Global Defense Agency and work by his rules
the white.
He hears that Cecil's actually rooting for him,
even though it sounds like he doesn't want
anything to do with him,
like he wants him to be true
when he says, I'm going to be good,
I'm not going to turn out like my father.
But he's right to be careful like he's no fool.
That's why he has all those contingency plans,
like the Rihanna men,
all the ways
that they're trying to affect Vulture. My cells.
like right now in his current state,
they could probably stop him if they needed to,
but given enough time,
he would theoretically become Invincible to them.
when he goes back to the GDF,
the monster that the Guardians
are in the middle of fighting is called The Giant.
He's basically like an eight year
old kid who fell through a portal with his grandma.
It was caused by a wizard into this war,
like into this giant form
that tried to use him against his enemies.
he wound up eventually breaking free.
Then he got banished by the people of that earth
back to the main version of Earth
where you now see him.
And that's why they make all these references
about him wanting to be an astronaut,
wanting to be president, United States.
he sounds like an eight year old kid
because he is literally an eight year
old kid in the body of a giant.
Basically, his problem is kind of
like the opposite of Monster Girl
because she's an adult woman
stuck with the reverse aging curse.
So she just looks like she's a little girl.
Jane is like a little kid trapped in a big person's
body.
they also use the scene here to remind you
that Donald's spine has finally healed
since the events of season one, when Omni-Man
crushed it, they basically explained, though,
that the Guardians aren't doing so hot as a team
that they don't have a lot of cohesion.
So they bring Immortal in as well as bulletproof
to try and beef up the team.
Robot is also still trying
to get used to his new body.
All the emotions that come with that,
like being an actual battle, as they say,
is basically feeling fear for the first time
because they used to just remote pilot
the robots from a distant location.
So it was more like him playing video games
as opposed to actually being in a fight.
then the Mueller's basically fixed
Engstrom Libby's machine.
They start to activate it, as he says he had
very altruist Dick reasons for wanting to do this.
But those wind up being perverted
through his own actions, causing that accident,
basically turning himself into a supervillain,
the whole idea is these corrupted
by the minds of all these alternate.
Engstrom Libby's who all hate their universe's
versions of invisible
because they all turn evil
and destroyed their worlds back at their home.
Olga comes back red, Russia's wife,
to check in on Mark's mother, see how she's doing.
I think the card that she left her
has something to do with the Global Defense Agency.
in, like I said, all this extra story with Mark's
mother wasn't part of the comics.
This is just them expanding her storyline.
everybody knows what's going on with mortal.
He's back after they put him back together.
Basically sewed Humpty Dumpty back together
at the end of season one.
Bulletproof is played by Jay Pharoah,
and he has a super WTA Back story.
Like he's not quite as powerful as Invincible,
but he's almost as powerful enough
to sub for him When Invincible leaves the planet
every once in a while.
Bulletproof was born with a twin brother
who experimented
on him against his will,
an attempt to give them both powers.
He basically used him
because they had identical DNA.
They were twins.
so the theory was if he could give his twin powers,
like if it worked,
he could use them on himself to give himself powers,
he wound up being successful, bulletproof
brother gave him powers,
but then wound up accidentally killing himself,
leaving bullet proof alive in the ashes,
he has a bunch of different powers.
Probably the most important one is the energy shield
that he generates.
It can absorb pretty much anything you throw at him.
He also doesn't need to eat or drink anything.
He can actually absorb energy, basically,
and turn that into sustenance.
He can fly. He has an enhanced healing factor.
He has superhuman speed, strength, reflexes,
like I said,
not quite as powerful as Invincible,
but still really, really strong.
in a scene that they're kind of
using him as a foil for explode on the team,
kind of putting him in his place.
Adam Eve comes back into the story to visit Mark.
They're still on really good terms.
She's kind of into him, but they're
mostly thinking of each other as friends right now.
That'll probably change by season three.
Like we're all kind of looking at our watches,
wondering
when they're actually going to get together
just because it's a real big thing in the comics
You can let me know
when you think that's going to happen.
Like I think is probably going to be season
three, maybe, maybe like the end of this season.
They'll tease that.
But the beginning of season three.
the whole idea now, though, is they both share very,
very traumatic backstories.
I did a video for like that whole separate Adam Eve
spin off episode is kind of like a prequel episode.
if you haven't seen it,
I would recommend checking it out.
I'll put a link for that
video down the description below
you thought that Invincible is back
story was messed up.
She takes that to like a whole new level
then Invincible agreeing to work
for seasonal arrives at Engstrom
Libby's to try and blow off some steam but winds up.
Falling to a bunch of multiverse versions of the
Mueller's that Engstrom Libby had working for him.
almost wind up killing him,
but not for Engstrom Libby stopping and accidentally
blowing up his own machine.
like I said, this is meant to be his tragic
supervillain origin story because originally
he had very good intentions Initially, the reason
why he didn't want the Mueller's to kill Invincible
is because he hated the idea of bloodshed,
but also eventually wanted to get Invincible.
His help in fixing the multiverse,
at least until his mind was corrupted.
now. We just want some cold, hard revenge.
But they are very clear to hammer home
the concept that Engstrom
levy is the reason why this accident
wound up happening.
Invincible is not to blame for anything,
the rest of the guardians of the Globe seem like
they're on Invincible side, except for the immortal
who's still really, really wary of him.
then, in the tag scene at the end of the episode,
they reveal what happened to Engstrom Libby.
He was disfigured in the accident.
His mind was corrupted, looking for revenge.
He looks just like he does in the comics.
Two really, really messed up,
then they do that standard Invincible title trope
that they do in most of the episodes
where they end the episode with him
not saying his name,
they just cut straight to the title,
but it's covered in blood for the acts
that just happened with the screen.
Cracked is meant to represent
the accident that just happened in the warehouse
with a small tag scene of the one surviving
mugler crawling away, complaining
about not working for anybody else ever again.
Overall, it was a great first episode.
Cannot wait to see how they follow this up.
The next three, there'll be four episodes
like I said, the first half of the season,
so I'll be doing weekly episode videos for it.
Make sure you enable alerts from my channel
so you don't miss any of that.
And there were so many Easter Eggs
and references in the episode,
like some of the stuff they're setting up.
if there was anything big in the episode
that I didn't mention in the video, just write it
below in the comments.
there's a bunch of really big stuff coming up.
They just dropped a brand new Echo Trailer
with Daredevil and Kingpin.
I'll do a video for that next.
That should post on Saturday morning in there.
My Boys Gen V finale video, and next week.
My Invincible episode too.
and my Loki finale video will be posted.
so there's just a lot of really big stuff happening
right now.
click here for my full Loki Season
2 Episode 5 video and click here
for all my other Invincible videos.
Thank you so much for watching.
Everyone. Stay safe
and I'll see you guys in the next one!